my head doesn't work right
I thought maybe these people can fix me
sounds stupid
that doesn't sound stupid to me what was
it like working together again and how
cool was it get back again so special
yeah honestly wick one of the crazy
things you realize I've been thinking
all about cos it of tonight is we've
been friends for a decade we work
together twelve years and then we've
been friends for that long we worked
together that long ago and when your
friends get successful they're always
making films so you never get to
actually really hang out that often and
it was besides just loving to work with
such an amazing actress I love spending
the time is literally like talking about
I love spending time with you I have to
play a variety of characters in this
movie so what were your favorites and
what what made that unique about playing
so many different characters how was
that unique
yeah I mean it was it was unique in a
lot of ways I thought you know it was so
much fun that we got to do that to get
speaking of that I think Joan is
incredible and I was just so excited to
get to work with him again in this way
so getting to do all of that together
and discover all those people together
was really did you have a favorite
person Linda yeah we're an old married
couple
in 1991 and she honestly you sounded
great and you looked great I liked your
wardrobe it didn't I didn't think he was
like corny I actually thought it was
like very cool I feel like I looked like
I lived in Brooklyn now super just bit
right in honestly it was just like she's
insane she's just like so good so
brilliant and it like
was she hates us but I I think it's so
fun like I I just love watching I get to
be friends with artists I really admire
that's pretty amazing and watched
someone I've been friends for so long
become so gifted and so recognized is
special